um turning now to overseas north korea
says it has test fired a missile with a
range to hit us military bases in the
western pacific and capable of carrying
a nuclear warhead it was the most
powerful missile that north korea has
tested since 2017 and the latest in a
series of launches this month elizabeth
palmer has more
so far
north korea has only released still
photos of sunday's launch from a mobile
vehicle near the chinese border
as well as pictures it says were taken
in space from a camera on the missile it
soared up more than a thousand miles
five times as high as the international
space station
then came down steeply and landed off
north korea's east coast but this model
the hwasong-12 can travel much further
over 1800 miles which puts u.s military
bases in guam and okinawa japan in range
in tokyo cabinet spokesman hirokazu
matsuno accused north korea of
threatening the peace and security of
japan and the international community
this january flurry of missile launches
some with the leader himself kim jong-un
observing has politicians and military
planners concerned
north korea insists they're technical
tryouts not political provocations but
they are certainly calculated to get the
world's attention
above all washington's kim jong-un wants
to see an end to u.s backed sanctions
against his country and the u.s would
like to see a big reduction in his
arsenal but seven launches into 2022
there is no sign that talks are imminent
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer
bangkok